something very different from our
intuition that we have from things like
engineering which says it's hard to get
complicated things actually in the
computational universe it's very easy to
get complicated things one important
feature of those complicated things is
this question about how time works and
the question is if you want to know what
is this thing going to do after a
billion steps how do you figure that out
well you might say well I'm you know I'm
going to use all kinds of fancy math and
all kinds of things like this and I'm
going to be able to figure out what does
this do after a billion steps I don't
actually have to run those billion steps
I'm going to I'm going to jump ahead and
figure out what it's going to do
it turns out that's not possible which
is a thing that you would think from you
know you'd say well we do science
science is about predicting things we we
you know we go further with science
we'll be able to predict it we'll we'll
get it eventually turns out that's not
the case and we've kind of known that
that's not the case in one way or
another for about 100 years now ever
since people started to understand the
notion of universal computation let me
explain how that how that works so so
one of the questions is when you see a
system like this you can ask kind of you
can think of what it's doing as a
computation it starts off with some
input it goes crunch crunch crunch it
generates some output question is sort
of how sophisticated is that computation
and in in the past before people maybe
you know 100 years ago people would have
said okay you want to make a an adding
machine you go buy the adding machine
from the adding machine store you're
multiplying machine's a different
machine then it was realized first in
the 1920s but then more clearly in the
1930s that no you could actually have a
universal machine where you have one
fixed piece of hardware and you just
feed it different programs to make it do
different things it wasn't obvious how
Universal that was so to speak that term
that it was possible to to do sort of at
the time it was thought to be sort of
any reasonable computation you could do
with let's say a turing machine that was
fed different programs
so the question is uh once once you have
this idea of universal computation you
you know that you you're going to have
some okay so back back to thinking about
different kinds of systems that do
computations and one question you might
ask is sort of how do these systems
compare is one of them kind of
computationally more sophisticated than
another or what and the thing that is
sort of a summary of lots of things that
I've kind of studied in the
computational universe is the thing I
call the principle of computational
equivalence which basically says that
when you look out in the computational
universe of all possible programs that
as soon as you see programs whose
behavior is not obviously simple it's
not just repetitive nested some some
very obvious regularity as soon as you
see behavior that is not obviously
simple most of the time the computations
that will be going on in that system
will be as sophisticated as the
computations that can happen in any
system
okay so what does that so this is by
principle of computational equivalence
what does it mean well what what is it
what what its consequences what has many
consequences but one of it's one of its
interesting consequences is a phenomenon
I call computationally reducibility
which um uh which is the following thing
so imagine that you are a predictor of
one of these systems and you are doing a
computation in your brain whatever else
and um uh okay so
if you want you don't have to
I was hoping to talk about some very
different kinds of things even different
things than I've ever talked about
before here but we're we're still in the
in the initial run-up here
um because I need to explain to you some
some basic concepts before we get get
too deep into other things all right so
principle of computational equivalence
idea is you're trying to predict what
the system is going to do you as a
predictor are doing computational things
the system is doing computational things
you expect you will be able to be sort
of smarter than the system itself and
even though it might take the system a
billion steps to figure out what it does
after a billion steps you will be able
to just work out some mathematical
formula or something and be able to jump
to the end and say this is what it's
going to do it's the typical experience
and kind of the mathematical equations
approach to science that you have you're
dealing with computational reducibility
in order to find out where sort of an
idealized Earth is going around an
idealized Sun you don't have to follow
you know a million orbits to know where
it's going to be a million years from
now you just have to plug a number into
a formula and get the results
but if these systems are computationally
equivalent if the predictor and the
system being predicted are
computationally equivalent in their
sophistic in their computational
sophistication you won't be able to do
that kind of jumping ahead so you'll be
stuck having to go through and say step
by step what does the system do and
that's you have to do sort of as much
computation as the system itself does so
in a sense that saying from within
science you were learning that science
has a certain fundamental limitation
it's not able to say what's going to
happen at the end without just
essentially running it and seeing what
happens now you might say that's a
terrible thing that's a limitation of
science it's a good thing for for the
existence of of like us humans because
if you think about you know the what's
the what are we achieving in life we
could say well you know people could say
well you don't need to live out your
lives we just know the answer in the end
is 42. we can just jump to the end and
see what the answer is but computational
irreducibility kind of makes it clear
that the past of time is kind of
achieving something it's the passage of
time is achieving this this irreducible
computation okay so that that's this
idea of computational irreducibility
will encounter it again the thing I was
just writing yesterday about kind of the
AI future is deeply deeply involved with
computational irreducibility but let's
let's talk about so one thing you might
say is well okay this idea about how
things are computational that's all well
and good but that's not how the universe
actually works
turns out it is how the universe
actually works and this is something
that I had long kind of suspected
um and about three years ago kind of
made a little bit of a technical
breakthrough which turned into a much
bigger thing and I think we can now be
fairly confident that we have a pretty
good model of kind of how fundamental
physics Works How the Universe kind of
works all the way down you just watched
a clip from the theories of everything
channel for the full video and all its
magnificence then click here and if
you'd like to see more then subscribe
enjoy